(gentle upbeat music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour,
it's always my joy and pleasure
to host these important conversations,
hard to believe this
is episode 39 already,
so I definitely appreciate all the support
that you all have given
and just all the feedback
from so many listeners, I
was just mentioning offline
with today's guests that I
actually came back from a talk
where some of the people
that were participating
in a research institute, actually looked
at one of our podcasts and
had a small group discussion
about it.
So it's really encouraging to
hear all the different ways
that you all are really
benefiting from this
and using it to help
you think about things
in a different kind of way.
So today I am honored to be
able to host a conversation
about topics that are near
and dear to this podcast,
we're going to be talking
about mental health
and the church, tension or
hope or even tension and hope,
and I'm honored to be able
to welcome a wonderful guest
to the podcast, today's
guest is Dr. Thema Bryant,
so Dr. Bryant, thank you
so much for being here.
- Oh, thank you so much for having me.
I'm so excited and have
been looking forward
to the conversation.
- Wonderful, well, I'm
definitely excited as well
and this is something that
I'm really curious to see
where we go cause there's
so many different directions
that we could take this conversation.
So just to give you all as listeners
a quick introduction to Dr. Thema
for those of you who might
not be familiar with her,
Dr. Thema is a tenured
Professor of Psychology
at Pepperdine University
where she also directs
the culture and trauma
research laboratory.
She is someone who has clinical interest
in interpersonal trauma,
also on societal trauma
and oppression and she's
been really instrumental
in her career over the years
really raising public awareness
regarding mental health
by extending the reach
of psychology beyond the academy
and also beyond private therapy
to really reach into communities
through things like community programming,
organizational consultation,
popular books and media engagement.
She's also the current president
of the American Psychological Association,
also known as the APA,
so a very influential
organization in this country,
which we'll hear more about
as we jump into the conversation,
she has numerous awards,
too many to mention here,
so I'm just going to leave it at that
and say that she does
have numerous awards,
but I do want to mention
a couple of the things
that she's involved in, so in addition
to being the APA president,
she hosts a podcast called Homecoming,
which is a mental health podcast,
she's also the Director of
the Mental Health Ministry
at her church, the First AME
church in South Los Angeles
and she's the author of
several books and articles,
one I wanted to mention
is called "Homecoming:
Overcome Fear and Trauma
to Reclaim Your Whole,
Authentic Self."
So someone who has definitely
been influential in society
and in the field and I'm
just grateful and honored
to be able to welcome her here
again to the program today.
- Oh, thank you so much for having me,
I really appreciate it
and we're excited at the American
Psychological Association
to get ready to host you as
one of our invited speakers
at the August annual convention
in Washington DC, so,
so much gratitude for
the work that you do.
- I definitely appreciate that,
I'm really looking forward to that
just be able to be
engaged with that group,
not to detract too much,
but that's to take me back a little bit
because as our listeners
know, I'm a neuroscientist,
but during my sabbatical a few years ago
I actually spent time with
clinical psychology interns
in the Bronx in New York
at Montefiore Hospital
and that really informed some of the work
that we're doing on this
podcast, so in a way,
the APA invitation is full circle for me
and I'm really excited about it.
- Oh, wonderful, I love that
and the application and integration
'cause often we have these
separate, profound conversations
that are happening in our sub
fields and sub-disciplines
and so when we can connect
and really exchange
across those different lines,
it's really phenomenal.
- Yeah, I definitely agree.
Well you're getting me
primed and ready already.
- Okay, good.
- Which is wonderful.
So as my listeners also know,
I always like to just
check in with our guests
to see where they are
at in this point in time
and how they're doing overall,
I think it's very appropriate,
but then also unfortunate
that we have to acknowledge
that even as we're recording,
we're only a couple days past
yet another school shooting
something that we've had
to talk about too often
on this podcast just
the frequency with which
that's happening and
definitely want to take time
to just commiserate and mourn
and grieve with all those
who are affected by
that, but in that spirit,
just want to see how you are
doing at this point in time,
just with everything that
we continue to navigate
as a society.
- Yes, so I am doing well,
even as I think about all of the traumas
that we are exposed to
in our individual lives
and also as a collective
and I am able to do well
I think by being mindful
of the number of people
who are working to make things better.
And so that nourishes me
so it doesn't feel like
me against the world, right?
There are many like-minded
people who are in their own way
or in their own discipline
or in their own communities
working for the transformation
and so that nourishes me
and then on a personal note,
I'm also a mom and my daughter
is a senior in high school,
so we are in that busy season
of college applications
and prom and graduation,
so that is really making
me thoughtful about season,
the time and the moment, you know,
that she'll be going into another season,
so, for each of us to think
about like the gift of now
and being present, you know, showing up
for those that we love
and so that really means a lot to me.
- Well, I really appreciate that
and that just sounds like
such a healthy perspective
to be able to hold all
those pieces together,
especially knowing that
there are challenges
that people are going through
but then as you mentioned,
knowing that there are
those who are about the work
and even as you were
talking as I was reflecting,
also just thinking about
someone like you and your role
and your focus on some of
the trauma informed work,
just wondering if you could
even expand on how you continue
to have that healthy balance
so much so that the work itself
or what you are helping
people navigate through
doesn't become overwhelming
for you on a day-to-day basis.
- Yeah, so thank you for that question,
a lot of times when people
hear that I'm along with being
an educator, I'm in practice
and working primarily
with trauma survivors and
so people will often say,
oh, that must be depressing,
but it actually is quite inspiring
because survivors are incredible people,
you know, they're, often, we wear it well
and people, if you just
encounter someone on the bus
or at work or in the
supermarket, you know,
you don't really know their story
but I get the opportunity
to be able to bear witness
and to hear people's stories and you know,
in that African-American culture
we would say kind of anyhow,
like what they have done anyhow is amazing
not only, you know, you think
about maybe professionally,
but personally to still
be a loving person,
to be a kind person, to
have grace is remarkable
given what some people have survived
and so seeing people's
courage and tenacity
to try to live well is remarkable
and then I also do work
on the side of prevention,
I think if you're only
working in the aftermath,
it can feel like, you
know, what's the point?
There's always like gonna
be another school shooting
or another sexual assault or another child
who's been abused, but
when you get to also work
in helping stop the cycle,
so not only do I work with survivors,
but I have also worked with
persons who have offended
and so knowing that it's a choice
and that people can make another choice
really helps me to keep showing up.
- Wow, there's a lot there
I think on both sides,
even aspects of grace and
things I wanna definitely
come back to and kinda
peel back the layers on.
Well, before we get there,
just also wondered if
you'd give our listeners
a little bit of a sense of
how you got into this work
in the first place and how
you developed this passion
for the work that you do.
- Yes, I love to share it,
I am actually a pastor's daughter, and so
within the African American community,
a lot of times people
feel more comfortable
talking to their minister than a therapist
or psychologist or social worker
and so growing up I often saw people
coming to meet really
with both of my parents
for what we would call pastoral
care or pastoral counseling,
in my book, "Homecoming,"
I say my teen years were
my first years working
at a crisis hotline
because people would just
call the house at all hours of night
and day just with
whatever they were holding
and so I learned very early I would be
what people would describe as sensitive,
and you can either think
of like sensitive people
as that's a problem or that's a resource
or a strength that we feel
things deeply and you know,
really empathize with others
and have a love for listening
and for being of service and so, you know,
I was exposed to pastoral
counseling and then I discovered
like that it's a field in and of itself,
this is like something
where people, you know,
focus their life's work
and on human behavior
and human interaction and
kind of working to the service
to better society and humanity,
and so initially I thought I
wanted to practice full-time
and then when I applied to Duke University
where we both attended,
they really have a focus
on those who wanna do research
and at first it wasn't a passion of mine,
but it's all about
getting the right exposure
and I ended up working with
a faculty member, Susan Roth,
who works from the perspective
of feminist psychology,
which means not just
looking at the individual
but paying attention to the
systems in which people live
and how to transform those
as well as individuals
and so that really got me excited
and also she does qualitative research,
which is documenting people's stories
and I love stories and I love storytelling
and so that got me interested in research
and teaching as well.
- Wow, that's wonderful
to hear about a journey
and so many different pieces, and again,
and one of the themes I keep
hearing as you're talking about
just how you're doing day to day,
when you're talking about your passion,
your educational experiences,
it's also just your
ability to kind of hold
different pieces together even
as you were thinking about
the individual, also
thinking about the systems
as you were talking about
the work that you've done
with those who are survivors,
but then also working with offenders
and so I think there's a lot of strength
that likely comes from that as well
and then even as you talked
about being empathetic
and seeing that as a strength
and a way to kind of navigate
and help people through because
I think in so many instances
people do see that, but they
also see or feel the burden
because maybe things aren't
and there's never any sense
of true balance, but things
are too skewed on one side
or the other, so I'm just
curious as I'm kind of reflecting
on what you're saying, if that's something
that you've actively thought about
or if it's just something
that has kind of come natural
to you in terms of holding
multiple perspectives together
at once.
- I love that and I
think it does capture it
that, you know, the way
I've thought about it
is being holistic, you know,
so mind, body, heart, spirit,
and also like perspective
taking right to, you know,
when clients come in and tell their story
or even sometimes I'm not
only working with individuals
but I work with couples and families
and so it's important to be
able to see the circumstance
from different angles
because two people as we know
can have the quote unquote same experience
and see it totally differently,
so it helps to be able to
kinda step outside of yourself
and to be more whole, right?
To be grounded in the fact
that we're complicated,
people are complicated, right?
And so what we try to
simplify it or only see people
as one thing or based on
one moment in their life,
we're missing the full story.
So I do aim to be holistic,
so my parents obviously
working in the church
were very much into spirituality,
but then they also were
very strong about education
and so it was important
for my brother and I
to really invest in our education
and then they taught us
that our culture was a gift,
so that, you know, just
being culturally rich
in high school, I was able
to move with my parents
to Liberia, West Africa,
so I think also living
outside of the states
gave me another vantage point
because I think sometimes
there can be a tendency
for us to center ourselves
as a nation and so to see like the world
beyond Baltimore where I was growing up,
really helped me to operate
I would say with a humility
and an appreciation for
the vast experiences
that people have.
- Wow, that's really great
and just even the privilege
to be able to have those
different experiences in different places,
funny that you mentioned Liberia
'cause the guests that we
had on the last episode
actually grew up in Liberia
before and after the Civil
War and just talked about one,
just the strength that he had from being
in such a strong community before the war
and how that really
helped him stay grounded
also part of the faith community
even as he moved through the Civil War
but then coming here to the
states as you talked about,
different perspectives,
realizing that he was African,
but then also realizing
that he was African American
and a little bit of both and
trying to navigate through that
with all the things that have
happened here in the states,
so again, just such a rich perspective
that he has had and which
it sounds like you've had
in some different ways as well,
which I think is really, really helpful
and we can also do that when
we're here in the states,
I think sometimes we
forget about that as well
and just the importance
of just being exposed
to people who aren't like us
and how much we can really learn.
- It's so true and
actually the war in Liberia
is in part how I ended
up focusing on trauma.
So we were there before the war
and then we ended up being evacuated
and it was that issue
of privilege as well,
you know, by being an American citizen
I was able to get on that
plane to go to safety
and so operating with that
awareness of, you know,
the impact of war, right?
Having loved ones who are lost
and just spaces and places,
the ways in which war disrupts so much
and so then it's not just like a metaphor
or something far away
that you see on the news
but experiencing it up close in a place
where there are not a lot
of licensed psychologists
and so, you know, then
asking that question of like,
how do we heal, right?
So that is a part of how I
ended up focusing on trauma.
- That makes a lot of sense
and I think it's really
telling in terms of just
all the perspectives
that you brought as well
and again, so many things
to kinda peel apart,
one question that I was just
gonna pull back to just,
you know, as I'm thinking about
as many people are
listening to this episode,
I think a comment that
you made earlier about
people being complicated, also realizing
that everybody's perspective or experience
in one situation can be so different,
I wonder, 'cause I'm imagining
some of our listeners
are hearing this, especially those
who maybe navigating with
people who are having
just challenges with everything going on
or even mental illness
and not always knowing
how to engage people, especially
if they feel like, okay,
well this is my loved one,
but I can clearly see that
the perspective is off
in this situation, how does
someone enter into that
without just saying, no, you're wrong,
while also trying to
understand and validate,
but then also kinda
help the person navigate
or get to a better place,
so anything you'd be willing
to share there?
- Sure.
So I think as you named first
being willing to listen,
I think often as soon as we
hear something we disagree with,
we jump in with a speech or with a debate
or with a correction and so
to start off with a curiosity
of like, you know, so tell
me how you landed there.
Like how did you come to believe that
or to know that and is
there any part of you
that feels torn about it?
Like is there any part of you
that you know, wonders about
is that the fullness of the story, right?
And so I think coming in with a curiosity
and a question is one piece,
I think another piece is
respecting our humanity
even when I don't have
respect for the opinion.
Right, so I feel like the
opinion is very problematic
and I have like no regard for that
but you are a human being
sitting across from me,
you are a member of my family
or whatever that connection
or relationship is and
so on that level alone,
you know, by my own values,
there are certain ways in
which I will not speak to you
or there are certain
ways I won't treat you
just as a result of honoring humanity.
And then I think it is also important
to give yourself permission
to speak the truth
as you know it because I, you know,
used to be one of those people
that would say, you know,
I'm not gonna say too
much to keep the peace
and then I had to say to myself,
whose peace are you keeping, right?
So the people who were saying
all kinds of outrageous
things, they feel peaceful
'cause nobody is like challenging them
or asking them a question, and so to say,
it's not just for me
to be internally upset
while everybody else is comfortable,
but I also have a right to express myself
and my viewpoint and you know,
developing the capacity to do that even
when you're with people who don't agree
and that was a good learning
for me because you know,
there were times in my life
where I was primarily surrounded
by people who agree with me,
so then there are some
things you don't even learn
how to articulate 'cause
everyone's always like,
yep, you know, you know, so we agree,
so it was a muscle I had to develop,
engaging with people who see
the world very differently
and learning how to, even if they're not
quote unquote convinced, but
at least being able to express,
you know, what I believe and why.
- That's so good, I mean, I
think listeners hearing that
will take so many practical tips away.
Even as you were talking I couldn't help
but not to politicize things
but I was thinking, wow,
if we could actually capture that,
especially the respecting humanity,
if we could capture that as a nation,
we would be in a very different place.
- Very different.
Very different and it
requires that sense of safety,
and I think a lot of
people even at this moment
don't feel safe, you
know, feel like, you know,
left to their own devices, other people
would either wipe me out
or wipe out my community
or would take away our rights
and all of these things,
so then when people are in a panic state
of feeling like that they are in danger,
then it's very hard to to
listen with compassion,
so that's why I think
we need kind of those
kind of commonalities and or ground rules
of there are some things
we can disagree on
while still honoring
each other's humanity,
James Baldwin said
something to the effect of
we can agree to disagree
or we can be in community
and disagree as long as our disagreement
is not a question of my
right to exist, right?
So that's that piece of,
there's a line, there is a line,
so yes we can have all kinds
of different viewpoints,
but when we start speaking
and moving in such a way
to deny people's right to exist,
well then you're gonna
get a different response.
- That's so good, so worth repeating
in lots of different
circumstances and situations
so we can remind ourselves
about that enough.
And again, so much to
think about, you know,
just in terms of one-on-one
individual conversation,
but even in terms of
nationally and societally,
which I think is a good segue as well
'cause I wondered if you give
people a little bit about
your journey to the APA and then also
what the APA represents and does.
- Yes, so it's been a beautiful journey
for me within the American
Psychological Association
and it starts with finding
like your common interest
or common community,
the American Psychological Association
is a huge organization
over 130,000 members
and so when we think about
notions such as belonging
or organizational home, for many of us,
you find a home within the home
and so we have different divisions
and one of the divisions is
a society for the psychology
of women.
And so that was kind of
my first home within APA
and connecting with
people who are committed
to bettering the lives of women and girls
and addressing our mental health issues
and so at the time, soon after I graduated
from graduate school, the president
for that women's division
was Jessica Henderson Daniel,
and she is a Black woman
who went on to become
APA'S first Black woman president.
So then it is not by accident, right,
that I am in this seat
now, mentorship matters
and she, you know, when I
graduated with my doctorate I was,
you know, in my early
twenties and she, you know,
took me under her wing,
it was a group of us
'cause one of her
initiatives was mentorship.
And so she had us all kind of
articulate professional goals
and then there were a group
of mentors to like help us
to navigate those spaces.
So, along with having a passion
for women's mental health,
I have a big interest in global issues
and so soon after I graduated
the American Psychological
Association, received
non-governmental organizational status
at the United Nations and
so they put out a call
that they were gonna
have six representatives
and I had just graduated, so I said, oh,
they're probably not gonna pick me,
but I'm gonna apply anyway
and this is an important point
for all of our students
or early career people
or even mid-career, don't
count yourself out, right?
Sometimes we eliminate ourselves,
it's like make them tell you no
instead of you telling yourself no
and so I was one of the applicants,
I got called into New
York for the interview,
they were picking, I
believe there were six of us
for that initial assignment
and at the interview
I was the only one in the interview
who mentioned racism and coming up
was the World Conference Against Racism,
so they needed one of
the six representatives
to cover that convention, and
so I ended up being selected
and so that was a big
part of my work in APA
and then working as a
leader and a researcher
in my work around trauma really
added to the contributions
around trauma psychology and so some,
maybe 10 years after that,
I had told my mentor,
the women's division is
division 35 and I said,
I wanna be president of
division 35 before I'm 35
and so I was like, you know that,
and so she said, are you willing to work?
And I said, yes.
She said, okay, we're
gonna make it happen,
so at 34 I was elected,
president they had had,
and it's funny how your
different training serves you,
when we had our first meeting,
they were all shocked and were like,
how'd you learn how to run a meeting?
They thought they were gonna
have to like handle things
but growing up in the black church,
there's a young people's division
and you run your own meetings
with "Robert's Rules of Order,"
like you know how to call for
a vote and all these things,
I was like, oh I've been doing that--
- You're seasoned already.
- So, it was a beautiful year,
well you operate as a
trio and then after that,
people kept planting the
seed of you should run
for president of the whole thing.
And initially it was
not an interest of mine
'cause I had my mind on I
wanted to do the women's group,
I did it, I'm kinda
finished and gone back to
my academic work and my private practice,
but you know, timing is
interesting and important,
so when people circled around
the most recent time and said,
there's a group of us
who want to support you,
are you willing to run?
And for the first time I thought about it
and especially as a trauma
psychologist, I was seeing both,
we were in the pandemic in
the realities of racial trauma
and I felt like this is the time.
So I entered the race,
I will say financially it
was a great year to run
because all of the campaign was online,
so you just send me the Zoom link
instead of having to like
fly all over the country
and you know, do all of that,
so virtual elections kind
of level the playing field
to some extent.
So I am really grateful and excited
about the work we've
been doing, so this 2023
is my presidential year,
but I remain on the board
for three years and my focus
areas are trauma, grief,
and oppression and just doing
some really exciting things.
- Yeah, that's wonderful to hear.
I mean, just the whole
navigation and story of it.
So, I mean, it sounds like
the need and your passion
met together and that's what shifted
your narrative in terms of
your willingness to jump in.
- Yes, of seeing this is
like, and years before me,
a lot of presidents
would make the argument
of how they could convince society
that psychology had something to offer
but the time that we were living in,
it's like all the
therapists I knew were full,
so it wasn't just a matter of
like trying to convince them
we have something to
offer is more the nation
and even the world or turning
to people of our profession
and saying, what can we do, right?
People are overwhelmed, the
grief, the stress, the loss,
and so it was just a
very different climate
where you're being
called on as a profession
to really fill a void
that as in human terms,
we'd never experienced
anything like this before,
like the numbers of losses, you know,
it was it is really life-changing.
- Yeah, and so important in so many ways
and I mean I can just hear
the passion in your voice
for all those pieces as well
and just, I mean, as you mentioned,
just it seems like there's
some gratitude also
about how people have now
caught the need and the vision.
But at the same time it
seems at least in my option,
there's still a tension there as well
because there's such a huge need,
so I'm also curious, and I'm
sure our listeners are curious
about you as an organization,
how do you address such a large need
where a lot of people are
saying this is invaluable
and others are saying there
aren't enough psychologists
especially if you think about,
I mean, just in society, on high schools,
on college campuses, how are you all
trying to navigate that?
- One of the things is trying
to increase the numbers
in the field and it is excited to report
out of the advanced placement courses,
the AP courses in high school,
we have AP psychology
classes and AP psychology
is right now the number one
choice among the sciences,
that so many students are
interested in selecting it,
they see how it connects to their lives
and so in that, working with educators
within the school system,
'cause one of the things
we know is people can't pick a career
if they never heard of it, right?
So it's like they heard of
like doctor, nurse, teacher,
firefighter, and so, raising the awareness
not only about the field of
psychology that it exists,
but also the range of things
that you can do with it
because, you know, from your own work,
knowing it's not only about
those who are in practice,
but the rich scientific work
that's being done, education,
and then we have applied psychology
or industrial organizational psychology
so, people who work, you know,
we talk about transforming systems.
and so you know, we at Pepperdine,
along with our doctoral program,
we have a master's program
and I tell our students,
whatever you ultimately choose to do,
this degree will serve you
because it's gonna involve people, right?
So even people end up going
into law or to business,
having a fundamental
understanding about psychology
can help them.
So, that's a part of the
work that we're doing
is trying to increase the field
and also trying to provide advocacy
using psychological science.
And so there are issues that
people are advocating for,
whether we're talking
about climate change,
about access to healthcare,
but being able to document which we can,
the psychological costs, consequences,
and even some solutions,
I think helps to inform
our policy makers, our legislators,
and so we just on this past Monday,
had one of our advocacy
days where our members
set up virtual meetings with senators
and with congressional
representatives about, you know,
some of the key issues in educating them,
we also provide testimony
on the hill about, you know,
whatever the issue, school shootings,
whatever it is people are facing,
what we can contribute to the conversation
so that we can come up with some solutions
that really have impact.
- I mean, that's encouraging
to hear how it's really cutting across
so many different domains and
systems, and as you mentioned,
because that psychology
is gonna be so important
in so many different ways,
I mean, a little bit,
maybe selfishly, just as I've
noticed with a neuroscience
and someone who does a lot
of behavioral neuroscience,
I've talked to university presidents
who are behavioral neuroscientists
and it's amazing seeing how
they navigate with people
just based on the way that
they watch people's behaviors
and how that has really helped them
in their leadership roles,
so I think what you've
mentioned to your students
is so important.
Even as you're talking about
policy, I mean, a lot of times,
probably the last 10 to 15
years we've talked a lot
in this country about needing to increase
our scientific literacy across society
but I think, if anything,
the pandemic has shown us
how important that is in terms of
our psychological understanding
and how much differently we would navigate
if we had that understanding
in the broader perspective.
- And how that even became politicized,
like these attacks on science
and so it was like, for some scientists,
it was their first time
ever for participating
in a protest march, it's like, you know,
people were thinking they picked a career
that was quote unquote
apolitical but, you know,
right, somehow, here we,
so, yeah, it's so important
and then when you brought up
this issue of leadership, you know,
with our researchers
find about the necessity
and the value of being
relational, you know,
whether we talk about
emotional intelligence
or social skills, however we name that,
that it's not just about the outcome,
meaning the labor or
like what are the goals
but as my mother would say,
it does matter how you treat people that,
so some of these wisdoms
that we find our grandmothers
or our culture could have taught us
but to be able to document
it, I think is so important
as well in terms of what
helps when you're trying to,
is it motivate people, mobilize people
and for sustainable change.
- Yeah, well, again,
I was already grateful
that you're in your role as president,
but feeling even more
grateful for the work
that you're doing and
I'm sure working in teams
to kinda move a lot of
these things forward
across society as well.
- Oh, thank you so much.
I am so excited, and you know,
one of the things I've
talked about or described
is as a movement in the sense
that many people are involved
and I tell people like 2023 is
a blip on the screen, right?
I get to president for this year
and then it's not gonna be my year anymore
but what encourages me
is there are so many
like-minded people in
various roles and positions,
within APA, outside of
APA, and so when we're all,
you know, moving at the same time
then we can really see
some great things happen.
- Yeah, really, really well said.
So I know we've also talked, you know,
speaking of relationships
and a relational things
and thinking about community,
we've also talked quite
a bit about aspects
of your faith growing up
and so I was curious if
you could bring that back
into the conversation, both
in terms of how as a field,
and I'm not speculating, but giving you
some of my observations,
it seems that psychology
has been more accepting
of the fact that faith
is a large part of people's lives,
so if you'd wanna comment on that,
and then also how that for you
is an integrated experience
as a psychologist and as a leader.
- Absolutely, I'm so excited to
be one of the many people who
is doing bridge building work
in this area that when the
field of psychology started,
you know, many of the
pioneers in the field
were people of faith, it
wasn't seen as attention
and psychology, you know,
literally means study of the soul,
but then as the field developed,
I think in some ways trying to
establish itself as a science
led some leaders in the
field to like disconnect
from spirituality and it can also be
like from their own experiences
when some people overgeneralize
and only see that faith-based
space as a place of shame
or a place of harm and what
I do is I hold both truths
and I encourage our students
to hold both truths,
which is there are people for whom
it has been a life-saving resource,
and that it's been healing
and nourishing and edifying,
and there are people who have
been harmed in those spaces.
And so, both things are true,
I think what ends up happening
is people go from one
extreme to the other,
so either if you experience it as harmful,
it's hard to see anything good about it,
or people who love it don't
believe any of the reports
that have come forward or
people who have been harmed
and so we, you know, wanna
be really careful about that
and recognize we never wanna put people
in a position where they feel
they have to choose, right?
So if psychologists say dismissive
things about your faith,
like I literally had a
client who shared with me
that their former therapist
was like very warm
until the client shared they
were in seminary training
to be a minister and then
the therapist responded,
you seem so smart, don't tell
me you believe that stuff.
Like what in the world?
Like what an attack on the
very core of this person,
so, there have been
statements like that directly
or indirectly that have been
made by people in the field
and then on the other side,
I have heard from pulpits and you know,
sermons where people will
say things like, you know,
you don't need therapy, you need to pray
and presenting this
false choice, you know,
I had a client who her
pastor literally told her,
you need to stop letting
those devil people
mess with your mind, I
already prayed for you.
And so, to stop creating attention,
but instead to recognize
that collectively,
we can provide the support
that people are so much
in need of, you know, I
have so much respect for
a lot of times faith communities
are like people's chosen home or family
in the sense that a lot,
especially black churches
will have programs all week long, right.
So as a therapist, I might, you know,
we might have one hour a week, right,
with 50 minutes an hour but
then the rest of the week
people may be like on their own,
so they may go like Monday
for choir rehearsal,
Tuesday, Bible study, Wednesday
they're helping to feed
the homeless and that is their community.
So there are things that we both give
and I think it just requires
greater understanding
of each other and respect.
- Yeah, it's so well said and I mean,
all those stories that you shared, I mean,
I think sometimes to your
point about people having
one perspective about faith,
either for or against based
on their personal experience,
then also it's sometimes hard to, again,
as you mentioned earlier,
think about an experience
outside of your own
and how important it is to
have that understanding,
but how much those comments
still happen on both sides
'cause I see them all the time as well,
whether I'm in the classroom or in the lab
or in the community, and just making sure
that people actually have an understanding
of what's happening in each space
and it's been encouraging, you know,
to see the way some of those
have turned into collaborations as well
which is really healthy.
- That's, you know, what's
been beautiful is, you know,
at my church in South Los Angeles
doing mental health
ministry, so, you know,
literally we'll do workshops
on dealing with holiday stress
or grief and loss, healthy
versus unhealthy relationships,
and so people, you know,
show up and they, you know,
want the knowledge, they
want the information,
and to have it in that
space lets them know
that it's okay to make use of it, right,
for it to be accessible.
I remember at one of my former churches,
the pastor talked openly in
her sermons about having gone
to therapy and it just gave
so many people permission
to feel like, like we
know she's holy, right?
We know like she prays all the time,
so if she could do, you
know, make use of it
then like, maybe it could help me too.
So I think, you know, it
can start from the top
in terms of leadership giving
more room and permission
and encouragement for people
to make use of the services.
- Yeah, that's really
true and really healthy.
Do you see any roles from
an organizational standpoint
for a group like the APA in
some of these conversations?
And if so, like what does
that look like exactly?
- Yes, so as I was mentioning,
we have multiple divisions
and even one of our divisions
has a focus on faith,
spirituality, and religion,
and so it covers all the
different domains of our work,
so in terms of research, it is important
to be able to explore both
quantitatively and qualitatively,
you know, what is the impact of faith
or being a part of a faith
community or faith practices,
what are things that
are helpful or harmful?
So, you know, there's
something called positive
religious coping or
negative religious coping,
so how you picture God or think about God
is gonna affect whether or not your faith
is de-stressing for you or
encouraging for you, right?
If you're thinking like,
there is this figure
that's out to get me and who's mad at me
and hear all these things, then yeah,
I'm gonna be stressed out
and then it's gonna be
a negative thing in my life,
versus, do I really
picture that as some source
that is loving, that cares about
me, that wants good for me,
then I'm gonna have a different
psychological experience
as I think about my
relationship with that.
And even for those who
may not be religious
in the sense of like belief in a God,
but as spiritual beings, you know,
what are those principles
that guide their lives?
Because I say wherever you
have human beings involved,
you're gonna have blessing
and difficulty, right,
so even some people who
will take the God part out,
but you have people
gathering for a book club
or gathering for yoga,
whatever you have people
gathering for, they're gonna
bring their stuff into it
and some of that will be edifying
and some of it will be destructive.
So yeah, we just wanna give
space for the truth of,
you know, we are works in progress
and to be able to see the
ideals or the principles
as opposed to people's
imperfect variations
of trying to live that out.
- Yeah, that's so well said,
reminds me of something you
said even before we started
this recording, just in
terms of also bringing
your whole authentic self
to this work as well,
and so I know you're talking
from a leadership position,
but it seems like there's also
aspects of leading by example
in your own life as well.
- Right, and that authentic truth-telling
to not have to pretend
to have all the answers,
or I think this is a big
one with faith leaders,
when people are in grief or trauma,
they're often asking us like, why?
Like, why did this happen?
And because there's not a
cookie cutter easy answer,
sometimes people have said
things that are harmful
just trying to create an answer
and so even for us to
give room for the mystery
to be able to say, I'm
not sure like, you know,
why your mom died so young
or, you know, and yet right,
we're here to be with each
other, to support each other,
so I think the humility and the honesty
really does much more
than trying to dictate
some fake answer.
- Yeah, yeah, it's a healthy place,
but not always an easy place to come to.
- Right, yep.
- So appreciate the way that, again,
you're leading by example and
then also just putting things
in place and having these
conversations and policies
to really help us get to that
place as a society as well.
- And mentioning policy,
when you asked about,
you know, things that APA is doing,
there are a group of psychologists now
that are working for some
guidelines to help people
who are in practice to know
how to integrate religion
and spirituality respectfully,
but appropriately,
so when we think about
like cultural awareness,
people often think about
race and ethnicity,
maybe they think about gender
sexuality or disability,
but religion often gets
left out and you know,
our researchers find in general,
the general public endorses
higher levels of religiosity
than mental health providers.
So we don't wanna leave it
out and want to help equip
those who are of service to others to know
how to integrate it appropriately.
- Yeah, that's so well said
and encouraging to know that
it's also based on the research
and what you're seeing as well
and then just anecdotally,
I've definitely seen that
in terms of the circles
that I've moved in, whether
that's in psychology circles
or even in scientific circles
at people who have been having
these diversity, equity,
inclusion conversations and realizing
that the faith component has
oftentimes been left out,
but I think especially the last few years,
realizing how harmful
that can be to pretend
that it doesn't exist, so.
- That's right, yeah, it's there
and then we can do harm
out of ignorance, you know,
like we have a clinic where
we provide community care
for like a lower rate and you know,
one of the students came to
me because she had a client
who was fasting and the
student was not familiar
with fasting, so, if you
don't know what that is,
sure you can, create in your minds
all kinds of things that
are problematic, right?
Or you can see a problem
where there's not a problem,
so, it's important for us
to provide the training
and the awareness so we
can have understanding.
- Also encouraging, I know
I've said this a few times
with the APAs, definitely in good hands.
- Oh, thank you so much,
I'm grateful for the opportunity to serve
and really blessed to be able to serve
with a number of really incredible people
and glad that you are
in the field as well.
- Yeah, I'm definitely grateful as well.
Well, this has been a
really rich conversation,
went too fast, so many things
we could have touched on,
but any last pieces that you
wanna leave the listeners with
in terms of what gives you
hope on a day-to-day basis?
- Yes, so I wanna say one of the things
that gives me hope is the
arts, artistic expression,
and so for us to think about
ways to both express ourselves
through the arts, but also to engage
with other people's artistry,
so that can be in music,
I tell people, think of a theme song,
play it in the morning
before you start working
or engaging with your
family, moving our bodies
or dancing, poetry, and
then some people will say,
I'm not artsy, but it
might be culinary arts,
the way you cook, the
way you wear your hair,
the way you decorate
your office or your home,
so that creativity, I think it helps us
to think out of the box,
which is always a good thing
and then the last thing I would just say
is to remember your own care,
often we are in service of other people,
but we don't wanna erase,
abandon, or neglect ourselves
and so I hope you will do
something for you on today.
- Well thank you so much
for sharing that with our
listeners, words of wisdom,
and for any who want to know more
or hear more about some of the things
that Dr. Thema has mentioned,
you can definitely
check out for TED Talks,
there's lots of rich
insights there as well.
So again, thank you so much for being here
on the Addy Hour podcast,
just for your work
and for all that you came to share
with our listeners as well
today definitely appreciate it.
- Oh, thank you so much,
I appreciate you having me.
- Of course.
(gentle upbeat music)